bonjour eric ciotti je vous remercie
beaucoup nous rejoindre car maintenant
d'être notre invité politique on vous
êtes député les républicains des
alpes-maritimes et vous êtes candidat à
la présidentielle via le congrès de
votre parti qui aura donc lieu début
décembre on va bien sûr en parler on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale aujourd'hui salle
bertrand bonjour du groupe la dépêche on
commence par l'actualité et la crise
sanitaire conseil de défense ce matin
avec notamment cette question est-ce
qu'il faut conditionner le pass
sanitaires à la troisième dose quel est
votre avis là-dessus c'est aux
scientifiques aux médecins de le dire
moi je fais confiance
à la science c'est pas une question
politique aussi pour vous d'un
gouvernement qui cherche à donges
fonctions fortement les français
savaient qu une question médicale voilà
moi je crois au vaccin
j'ai voté le projet de loi sur la loi
sur le passage du ter parce que je
considérais que c'était important j'ai
plus de réserves sur le débat actuel
pour le prolonger jusqu'à l'été parce
que ça se ferait sans aucun contrôle du
parlement donc le cadre qui nous est
proposé ne me convient pas mais moi je
crois et je le dis à nos concitoyens ou
allongés jusqu'où du coup jusqu'en
février comme semblent le dire la droite
sénatoriale ou aurélien pradié qui était
sur ce plateau la semaine dernière lui
ne disait pas au delà du 15 novembre
là encore c'est une question médicale je
crois qu'elle doit dépasser les
questions politiques il faut que le plus
de france est possible soit vacciné je
le crois profondément et le pass and i
ter contribuer à inciter à la
vaccination s'est échangé au delà du
rôle donc il faut que le plus largement
possible et y compris les personnes qui
sont encore vulnérables soient vaccinés
moi je crois profondément à ce vaccin
finalement on a eu une chance
que la communauté médicale
internationale trouve en un temps
extraordinairement limiter un vaccin ce
vaccin à sauver des vies j'avoue ne pas
comprendre les polémiques qui s'ils sont
agrégés le complotisme qui s'est exprimé
voilà je crois encore une fois au
progrès à la science c'est aux médecins
de nous dire jusqu'à quand ça doit durer
concernant le poste sanitaire oliveira a
semblé ouvrir une porte quand même hier
en disant que vous sur le parlement
serait reconsulter de toute manière un
mois avant sa remise en place si elle
était nécessaire ça vous suffit pas ça
le problème c'est que le parlement
normalement ne doit plus siéger à la
veille de l'élection présidentielle donc
cette consultation elle sera un peu un
peu virtuel je crois qu'on peut se
limiter justement
personnellement jusqu'au mois de février
ça me paraîtrait plus raisonnable
l'autre sujet qui inquiète c'est là aux
allures en carburant
elle fait monter la colère et le
gouvernement réfléchit à différentes
mesures à mettre en place ils sont
penchés pour un chèque essence est ce
que ça vous paraît être une bonne idée
moi j'ai une proposition claire plus
simple je suis pas pour la politique du
chéquier parce que au bout d'un moment
il a ses limites moi je suis pour la
baisse de la fiscalité et aujourd'hui on
a sur le prix du carburant une
aberration totale il y à la taxe
intérieure sur les carburants et les
produits énergétiques qui est déjà très
lourdes sur le prix d'un litre d'essence
c'est environ 60 centimes de taxe est
gigantesque et sur cette taxe il y a
également la tva qui est prélevé donc on
paye l'impôt sur l'impôt moi je propose
qu'on supprime la tva sur cette partie
ce qui aboutirait à une diminution
d'environ 15 centimes du prix du litre
10 % ça serait substantiel et durable
c'est une injure on supprime la taxe sur
la taxe exactement par la différence
avec un chèque qui est un coup en selle
à damas et pérenne ça serait durable et
puis la tva aujourd'hui l'augmentation
du prix du carburant du prix de
l'énergie en général abouti à enrichir
l'état voilà depuis le début septembre
depuis l'augmentation même un peu plus
tôt l'état a perçu 2 milliards d'euros
de recettes fiscales en plus et il a
restitué au travers du chèque énergie
environ 500 millions donc
l'enrichissement continue ce que je dis
c'est que ce qu'a gagné l'état il faut
qu'ils soient restitués
la baisse profiterait tout le monde les
partisans du chèque énergie 10 mais du
coup on fait quelque chose de plus
ciblées qui touche uniquement les
français qui n'ont pas les moyens de se
payer ce prix assure plein d'essence
est-ce que c'est pas vous tout le monde
tout le monde travaille voilà et cette
différenciation d'abord c'est une usine
à gaz si j'ose l'expression en la
matière totalement
extraordinairement difficile à mettre en
place complexe il faut une mesure simple
lisible on ne paye pas l'impôt sur
l'impôt est en baisse de 10% le prix du
carburant ce que c'est l'état bien
restitue au français ce qu'il a perçu
finalement de façon un peu un dieu est
ce que c'est le bon moment au moment où
on dit que l'état beaucoup dépensé
durant la crise du que vides en plan de
relance est ce que c'est le bon moment
de se priver d'une partie des recettes
l'état beaucoup dépensé ce qui a conduit
d'ailleurs un niveau d'endettement
gigantesques ont démonté le budget 2022
prévoit 3000 milliards d'euros de dette
on est à plus de 115 % de notre richesse
nationale
ça nous met dans la catégorie des pays
du sud de l'europe et ça nous met dans
une zone de fragilité terrible on a
parallèlement des déficits qui sont
gigantesques
déficits budgétaires des déficits
commerciaux aussi ce qu'il faut c'est
aujourd'hui réduire les dépenses
publiques
bien sûr il faut réduire et maintenance
public parce que au-delà de la crise
sanitaire qui a nécessité j'en conviens
un effort exceptionnel on a augmenté
depuis trois ans de 100 milliards
d'euros nos dépenses publiques hors
crise sanitaire c'est ces gigantesques
et on voit bien aujourd'hui que le
président macron étant dans une campagne
électorale
il se promène il fait le tour de france
carte bancaire ou chéquier selon le mode
de paiement que l'on veut devant toutes
les catégories chaque fois qu'ils
expriment un propos d' qui tient un
discours c'est un milliard c'est 500
millions c'est 2 milliards il faut
arrêter et il faut avoir le courage de
dire on réduit les dépenses publiques
mais
dans mon programme j'ai des propositions
très concrètes sur la baisse des
dépenses publiques il faut avoir le
courage enfin de le faire parce
qu'autrement on va aller dans le mur on
ment aux français on tire une hypothèque
sur les générations à venir qui devront
rembourser la dette et la dette on va la
rembourser jusqu'en moment où les taux
d'intérêt vont s'accroître et nous
fragiliseront
et nous serons contraints nouveau
augmenter les impôts c'est une spirale
que je refuse donc il faut diminuer les
dépenses publiques si on porte l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 65 ans et 20
milliards d'euros de gains de dépenses
publiques quand vous 65 pas au delà et
doigt sur dix 60 on peut aller jusqu'à
65 ans et 65 au nez à 62 aujourd'hui je
propose d'aller vers 65 d'ici 2027 sur
la durée du quinquennat si on diminue le
nombre de fonctionnaires je propose le
150000 c'est une économie de dépenses
lors j'ai des propositions très claires
dans certaines agences qui se sont
multipliés de façon un peu un dut en
réorganisant l'état avec un rôle accru
des préfets de départements au détriment
des crampes des agences régionales je
pense aux ars dont je propose la
suppression je demande aussi une grande
réforme territoriale avec deux échelons
territoriaux la commune cellule de base
de la démocratie conforter et puis une
collectivité aux côtés de la commune qui
regrouperait aujourd'hui région
département métropole c'est un peu
brouillon du conseil les cellules assuré
pour les territoires c'est celle retour
je conseille sans rien si ce n'est que
là il y aurait plus qu'une collectivité
dans environ d'environ 500 de province
en france donc des collectivités entre
800 mille et un million et demi
d'habitants selon la la réalité des
territoires autour des villes centres
simplification gain d'argent public je
sens cet exemple et territoriales et
souvenez que c'est en grande partie ce
qui avait fait perdre la droite et fait
perdre le sénat à la droite en 2008 vous
n'êtes pas inquiet je comprends pas que
c'est ça qui est fait perdre le sénat la
droite ce qui avait fait perdre le sénat
s'était d'entrée chèques aux élections
municipales
voilà non c'est une réforme de bon sens
qui est il on ne veut plus répéter dans
ce mécano extraordinairement
plex sur nos territoires on voit les
lois tout aussi compliqué porté par le
gouvernement actuel cadets 3ds enfonçait
même même les noms sont compliquées il y
a aucune avancée en termes de
décentralisation et finalement on a
assisté dans ce quinquennat une
recentralisation et avec une gabegie de
moyens voilà donc on peut si on a le
courage moi je veux porter un projet de
courage innovant nouveau on peut réduire
la dépense publique c'est un choix c'est
un impératif parce que l'herbe des
baisses de la dépense publique elle
conditionnera la baisse des impôts on ne
peut plus là aussi être le pays au monde
où on paie le plus d'impôts et de
charges pourquoi parce que ça aubert la
compétitivité nos entreprises d'où le
déficit commercial qui est de plus en
plus élevés on est plus compétitif on
s'est désindustrialisée les entreprises
se sont délocalisés on a fragilisé des
territoires tout se tient mais au départ
c'est parce qu'il ya trop de dépenses
publiques qui conduisent à trop d'impôts
etc ça vous dit aujourd'hui et bien
fragilise tellement notre pays s'il faut
vendre cette spirale et de supprimer les
grandes agences d'état ça fait 250 mille
fonctionnaires ça
déjà si on en suit prix rs par et non ça
fait pas de sens à mal les
fonctionnaires mais
dans la réforme des collectivités
territoriales que j'évoquais il y à un
gain important il ya aujourd'hui vous
demandez la mission publique
territoriale il ya un million neuf cent
mille agents dans la fonction publique
territoriale les intercommunalités ont
crû de façon inconsidérée aussi au cours
des dernières années ont supprimé alors
que les effectifs dans les mairies n'ont
pas diminué à proportion
l'intercommunalité c'était censé faire
de la rationalité la cour des comptes
l'a dit moi j'ai présidé pendant devant
le conseil général des alpes-maritimes
quand je suis arrivé en 2008 y avait
5000 sans agent 5200 presque quand je
suis parti en 2017 y en avait quatre
mille trois cents sans heurts dans la
sérénité sans que le service public soit
affaiblie on a aujourd'hui un million de
fonctionnaires de plus qu'un allemagne
et est ce que l'allemagne à un service
public plus dégradée que la france je ne
crois pas on a ce paradoxe ou plus s'il
ya des moyens plus ya de fonctionnaires
plus les français ressentent un service
public on l'a vu pour la santé
fragilisée on le voit pour la sécurité
fragilisé donc c'est pas que simplement
une question moyens d'organisation de
services publics fragilisés avant-hier
le président de la république annoncé
des états généraux de la justice
c'était nécessaire selon vous
l'ancien gardien c'est aux gens là que
voir si parler de clochardisation
c'est ce mot il résume assez bien la
situation de notre justice en français
on parlait à l'instant de dépenses
publiques quand on dépense 1000 euros
dépenses publiques seuls 4 euros sont
consacrés à la justice ce qui a conduit
à une véritable paupérisation de notre
justice nous avons deux fois moins de
juges que la moyenne de l'union
européenne 4 deux juges du siège ont
embauché quatre fois moindre procureur
sur le régalien d'ailleurs mes
propositions diminution exonère à la
fois le secteur de la justice de la
sécurité de la défense mais aussi les
soignants je le dis très clairement je
le je le précise oui il faut des moyens
humains supplémentaires pour la justice
il faut aussi une réponse pénale qui
permettent d'exécuter des peines qui se
deviennent rapides et donc dissuasive
aujourd'hui il faut savoir le garde des
sceaux m'a répondu à une question écrite
il ya que la semaine dernière 83 mille
peines de prison ferme définitive
exécutoire ne sont pas aujourd'hui
exécutés sont en attente d'exécution ça
veut dire que la sanction pénale elle ne
s'applique pas aux elle s'applique très
mal pour le sable de l'arsenal yeux
surtout quoi il peut y avoir un manque
de personnel dans la chaîne de
l'exécution des peines qu'il faut
fluidifier mais surtout parce que nous
manquons cruellement de places de prison
c'est ça le problème pour être
c'est la fin du xvème en mille places de
prison d'ici 2027 nous en avons
aujourd'hui 62000 très peu ont été
construites sous le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron à peine un peu plus de
2500 c'est là la réalité c'est moins
souvent soir-là en 2000 quasiment 2000
avec un objectif de 7000 places lancé
oui l'objectif mais on est à quelques
mois de la fin du quinquennat donc c'est
un effet d'annonce cet objectif cet
engagement je vous rappelle qu'il était
de 15000 places porté par emmanuel
macron en 2000
17 n'a absolument pas été tenus et c'est
ça qui grippent toute la chaîne pénale
c'est ça qui qui freine le brader des
magistrats aussi parce qu' il y a une
forme de numerus clausus qui ne dit pas
son nom parce qu'on incarcère pas
certaines personnes qui devraient être
incarcérés notamment tout ce qui touche
un policier un gendarme qui portent
atteinte à l'autorité de l'état pour moi
ils devraient le soir même dormir en
prison aujourd'hui on ne va pas vers
cette sévérité parce qu' il peut y avoir
des questions idéologiques mais il y a
aussi ce contingentement matériel qui
obèrent qui grippe la chaîne une
question d'actualité et christelle va
vous interroger sur les républicains
après mes dernières questions
d'actualité c'est le tribunal qui a
ordonné hier que nicolas sarkozy soit
années devant lui par la force publique
pour qu'il soit témoin dans le procès
des sondages de l'elysée qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de cette méthode écouter
nicolas sarkozy a toujours déféré à
toutes les demandes de la justice donc
je troll en l'occurrence il ne voulait
pas y aller il est protégé par son jeu
sur une nouvelle fois un peu humiliante
rien n'aura été parti à nicolas sarkozy
on peut même se demander s'il est un
justiciable comme les autres il les a
charmés rejet c'est sûr qu'ils soient
jugés moins sévèrement mais pas aussi
plus sévèrement et là on a véritablement
le sentiment d'une forme d'acharnement
permanents
étaient conviés à partager un petit
déjeuner au siège des républicains avec
les autres candidats à la primaire
comment ça s'est passé on a envie de
nous demander une bonne ambiance oui vos
l'ambiance est d'ailleurs et c'est pas
un élément
qui ressort d'une forme de langue de
bois je crois qu'entre nous on s'entend
bien il n'y a pas de conflit
qui ne date diereman et xavier bertrand
qui elle-même tarder ont des lois j'ai
des relations personnelles de amical que
ce soit avec valérie pécresse avec
michel barnier avec xavier bertrand n'y
a pas de problème je crois que on se
parle tous voilà il ya une compétition
on a défini les règles pour que ces
règles soient transparentes on est tous
animés je crois par un esprit de
responsabilité on mesure l'enjeu l'enjeu
c'est c'est pas simplement la survie de
notre famille politique
parce que si on n'est pas au second tour
notre survie sera en jeu mais ça c'est
pas l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est de redresser le pays
on partage tous le constat d'un
déclassement d'un affaiblissement de la
france et on a le sentiment et j'ai la
conviction que seul un candidat issu de
la famille de la droite républicaine
pour abattre emmanuel macron moi je
considère qu' il ne faut plus qu
emmanuel macron fasse un nouveau
quinquennat s'il reste à l'elysée s'il
continue la politique a tellement
affaibli la france ça sera
catastrophique pour notre pays il faut
dire cette vérité le en même temps
l'immobilisme l'absence de réformes
l'absence de courage contre
l'immigration incontrôlée contre
l'islamisme contre cette dérive
économique nous évoquions et bien elle
conduit à déclasser notre pays alala
placé en seconde division des nations
donc il faut qu emmanuel macron soit
battue est le seul candidat qui puisse
le battre sera celui qui est issu des
républicains autrement avant tout dans
ce que disent les sondages pendant
toutes les autres solutions toutes les
autres solutions conduiront une défaite
vous conviendrez que les seules
l'hypothèse où emmanuel macron peut être
mis en difficulté c'est lorsqu'il est au
second tour face à 15 ml 1 c
est donc pour accéder au second tour il
faut une candidature forte unique et il
faut des idées fortes et c'est ici dès
que je veux porter dans ce débat donc ça
veut dire que vous engagez à soutenir le
candidat désigné à l'islam mais
actuellement on a tous on s'est tous
engagés à cela lorsqu'on a déposé notre
candidature on a signé un acte
d'engagement en ce sens vous êtes engagé
aussi avoir des débats entre vous avant
le premier tour de la primaire est ce
que vous ne craignez pas que ça puisse
déraper à un moment ou un autre
comment faire là encore
chacun un esprit de responsabilité il y
aura des différences il faut qu'elle
apparaisse mais ça y est c'est il y aura
bien des débats riches il y aura des
débats en tout cas personnellement je le
souhaite christian jacq monde le
souhaitent christian jacob
je veux rendre hommage parce que si on
était tous autour de cette table c'était
une photo c'était un symbole c'est le
fruit d'un énorme travail de
conciliation de rassemblement tout le
monde est revenu dans la famille vous
fait doucement que xavier bertrand il
verrait bien sûr que c'était une très
bonne nouvelle tout le monde aujourd'hui
dans la famille on a été très loin en
juin 2019 où on voyait tout le monde
qu'ils s'écartent et voilà tout le monde
est revenu c'est déjà un premier succès
c'était hier un aboutissement ça doit
être un départ aussi un départ pour dire
aux français voilà on a un projet et il
est crédible il est solide on a une
expérience de gouvernement
on a une équipe
faites nous confiance pour redresser le
pays parce que toutes les autres voies
sont des voies qui vont conduire au
maintien d' emmanuel macron en fonction
tout le monde mais pas les centres
historiques ce tiers y avait mon rang à
votre place qui disait que c'était idiot
c'est son idiot d'avoir exclu les
centristes de votre choix pour la
présidentielle qu'est ce que vous dites
à temps soit on faisait une primaire
ouverte à tout le monde et naturellement
dans ce cadre chacun pouvait y
participer soit c'était notre famille
politique qui désigne son candidat
il a
[Musique]
ce sont les mains élèves qui ont choisi
mais on s'entend bien avec avec les
centristes et un candidat avec avec
hervé morin il y aura forcément un
candidat commun il peut pas en être
autrement et puis on travaille d'ores et
déjà sur les élections législatives dans
quelques instants se tiendra la première
commission nationale d'investiture et
honorât des circonscriptions où on aura
un candidat commun que ce soit et sans
tri soit avec lui des idées vous serez
candidat aux législatives
oui bien sûr bien sûr avec un risque
d'avoir contre voit un candidat soutenu
par christian estrosi avait tu risques
et cette législative pour vous christian
estrosi aujourd'hui en marche il
soutient emmanuel macron il y aura sans
doute un candidat en marche entre mois
comme la dernière fois sans jamais me
met très difficile à mener la dernière
fois le soutien avait été un peu au
culte mais il était très important cette
fois il sera plus visible ça me fait pas
peur au contraire j'aime bien la clarté
pour en revenir à la primaire où en êtes
vous de vos parrainages ou devait
chapeau chacun chaque candidat doit
avoir 250 parrainage je serai candidat
sans difficulté le 4 décembre les avez
vous en avez combien aujourd'hui j'ai
quasiment la totalité des parrainages
mais encore deux semaines pour les ont
fait d'inquiétudes pour les recueillir
dernière question incontournable
eric zemmour semble monter toujours dans
les dans les sondages vous avez affiché
une certaine proximité avec lui est ce
que vous le regrettez aujourd'hui dans
le cadre de cette ce débat sur les
primaires ou est-ce que vous assumez
j'ai envie de vous dire je pourrais
chanter mais ça risquerait de contrarier
la météo non je ne regrette rien voilà
j'assume mes choix je suis pas quelqu'un
qui change de conviction au fil du temps
ou du vent voilà j'ai découvert dont
j'avais rêvé manuellement oui je le
redis
je partage une partie du constat que
dresse eric zemmour quand il décrit une
france en déclin
menacés par l'islamisme par une
immigration de masse
il est inutile de nier ce constat ce
constat je le fais depuis des années
donc ça serait assez ridicule mais en
prêt à jouer en candidat à la région
alsace je dis très clairement que ma
conviction ou par ma certitude que seul
donc je n'ai bien seul incarner dans l
air peut gagner cette élection
présidentielle parce que je pense
qu'eric zemmour aura très exactement
face emmanuel macron là même le même
plafond de verre qui existent
aujourd'hui qui existait jusqu'à une
alliance avec les règlements moi je ne
suis persuadé que notre je me bats dans
ma famille politique je ne les jamais
quitté j'ai adhéré au rpr à 16 ans en
1981 j'ai traversé avec des amis solide
comme me christian jacob comme laurent
wauquiez toutes les tempêtes et je me
battrai jusqu'à avec toute mon énergie
pour que notre famille politique donne
le meilleur d'elle même pour redresser
la france je ne suis dans aucune autre
solution donc si vous n'êtes pas au
second tour et sir examiner ça fait
beaucoup de si un jour la corde mais ça
veut dire que vous appeler à voter pour
lui sans aucune condition pas d'alliance
à 7 à cette question j'ai répondu entre
macro et zemmour
mais je le dis et je préfère et moore
mais je dis très clairement c'est une
hypothèse qui me paraît très improbable
et que si elle devait se place se poser
elle conduirait à la réélection des
manuels macron donc c'est pas
l'hypothèse sur laquelle naturellement
je me base je me fonde et je porte mon
engagement et mes idées merci
[Musique]